i just asked your age 19 and so how old
were you when i first met you which was
that ellen yes yes and you were
performing the sea of video live in
front of everybody you were about to
you know be so groundbreaking the two of
you thank you i really appreciate it i
think i was 11.
yeah
so it was a really long time ago and i
always remember meeting you and i i'll
never forget that it was so cool for me
well i was so moved by what you and cia
were doing it was
performance art but it didn't have a
wall up to it yeah totally it was
breaking walls down thank you but in the
coolest most profound talented artistic
i mean you two really have an incredible
connection and i do believe in the muse
thank you yeah i can't believe she
trusted me with that kind of
responsibility but it was a wild ride
and i'm so grateful for the experience
just kind of like everything i learned
as a dancer was kind of broken down like
you said when i started working with her
and i learned that flaws were beautiful
and i learned that not everything had to
be so calculated and perfect and
was that counterintuitive to what you
had been learning thus far
totally well the person who changed my
life when i was six years old
and i tried to be his muse
steven spielberg you're in his latest
movie west side story break it down
how's it working with steven
i mean you know he's like
seriously one of the most incredible
people i've ever met i was so lucky to
do that i was 16 when i filmed that and
i was definitely one of the youngest
cast members and i was just like
absorbing every moment i was just trying
to like really just
be present in every moment i could i i
absolutely adored the experience it was
so fun i mean he is so what he's such a
like
dad
i love it he's you know i saw him as
more of like a father figure growing up
totally but now that i'm older and he
knows my little kids and we've come
sort of full circle i'm like god you're
so cool no he's the coolest he's so and
i mean like hip trendy yeah up on
everything like hangs hard with the kids
like that all the dad vibes i would get
from him growing up
but he still has those two he's so
nervous i know i love it i love it so
much okay um now uh
my daughter just got into
a little dance troupe she made uh the
auditions and she is in a little dance
troupe now um
she has an outfit for all matching
maddie may i ask some
maternal advice of course um as we both
know being a kid and an adult and an
adult and a kid
how
what's your advice for me yeah um this
is something that i really realized as
i've started to get a little older is
that i was taught to like
stay so focused and not engaged with
your competitors or your other whether
it be a different studio or even your
own teammates and i think like i
realized that winning means nothing
that the only thing that really mattered
and i wish i took more seriously was
really having community with my friends
and supporting them and
being inspired by them and rather
not be scared of the people who might be
better than you but actually just enjoy
it and learn something from them and i i
really that's the best advice i could
try and possibly give is just like
accomplishments are cool but they're not
everything
and finding community in your friends is
the most important thing well you'll be
so proud to hear she ran out of the
class in the freezing cold the other day
and other night in her t-shirt so that
she could give her
fellow dancers and her troop like little
presents i love it and i was like oh no
i love it
okay
we have a segment on the show here
called dear drew and it is all dedicated
to my love of snail mail
i'm not alone here i'm obsessed with
like the smell
of mail
how did this start i don't know and i i
also don't know how anyone found this
out about me and i'm kind of weirded out
by it but i i thank you producer you
said in our research i was like why did
i say that a long time ago no but i
absolutely am obsessed with i wish i
could just put it into a bottle and
spray it on me that's perfume i i'm so
happy you like this because my family
makes fun of me for it and i'm like
literally i walk in and i just like
really embrace everything that's going
on in the moment please ever do a dear
drew with me if i would love to okay
this is a date
um okay
tell me about the film that is uh coming
out it's the fallout yes it's uh really
winning awards critical darling people
are freaking out tell me about it yeah
i'm i'm so lucky to be a part of it the
fallout is a coming-of-age story of
these high school students
who kind of share a unique bond and
navigating love and self-discovery and
healing uh kind of in the aftermath of a
tragedy that happens yeah i was shocked
when i was watching it and understood
what the premise was because i didn't
know going into it and it hits you quick
yeah i'm also amazed that there's a film
being made about that subject
considering it's something i don't want
it to be the case but people are going
through totally and it's something that
needs to be talked about just because
it's
the realistic you know way of the world
and
it's unfortunate it really is and
there's so much fear that high school
students must face every day but
it's it needs to be talked about
[Music]
you